معنا من امام مستشفى شهداء الاقصى في دير
البلح مراسلنا هشام زقوت هشام مام رد هذا
التجمع من
خلفك الزملاء الصحفيون يلقون نظره الوداع
على زميلنا جبر ابو هدروس الذي استشهد من
جراء قصف الاحتلال الاسرائيلي لمنزله هو
وسته افراد من عائلته الزملاء يلقون نظره
الوداع وايضا يشيعون بعد قليل جثمان
الزميل جبر الى مثواه الاخير في مقبره
الشهداء هنا في دير البلح حيث سيجري دفنه
هو وجميع عائله افراد عائلته مع بعضهم
البعض لا سما واننا كما نعلم ان المقابر
باتت ممتلئه في هذه المنطقه عن بكره ابيها
جراء استمرار القصف الاسرائيلي واستمرار
سقوط شهداء بالعشرات عمليه التشييع
لجثامين عدد من الشهداء ستتم هنا بعد قليل
ايضا نحو 14 شهيدا من جراء عملي القصف
الاسرائيلي المستمره على مناطق وسط قطاع
غزه القصف بات مكثفا على هذه المناطق لا
سما وان الجيش الاسرائيلي بدا بدا عمليه
بريه انطلاقا من مخيم البريج في هذه
المنطقه الوسطى وبات يكثف من غاراته
باتجاه هذه المناطق الوسطى مخيم المغازي
ومخيم البريج ومخيم النصيرات وايضا منطقه
الزوايده ودير البلح الزميل جبر استشهد في
منزل بعدما قصفته الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه وسوته بالارض وتم انتشال
جثمانه وكان يعني في اللحظات الاخيره لكنه
فارق الحياه واستشهد بعد ان وصل الى هذا
المشفى هو وسته افراد من عائلته الزميل
جبر يسكن في مخيم النصيرات في في مخيم
اثنين وبعض المربعات السكنيه ربما ابلغهم
الجيش الاسرائيلي بان يتوجهوا الى منطقه
دير البلح وبعض المربعات في مخيم النصيرات
بالتحديد ومخيم البريج لكن لكن هذه
المنطقه التي قصف فيها الزميل جبر هي من
المناطق التي لم يبلغ الجيش الاسرائيلي
السكان بالاخلاء الى دير البلح وبمعنى ان
هذه المنطقه كانت مكتظه بالسكان كان
النازحون يلجؤون اليها لاسما وانها لم
تبلغ به بعمليه الاخلاء ولكن رغم كل ذلك
قصفهم الجيش الاسرائيلي هناك ما زالت حتى
عمليات البحث من قبل طواقم الدفاع المدني
جاريه في كل المناطق التي تعرضت للاستهداف
والتي يمكن الوصول اليها سما وان بعض
المناطق لا سما مخيم البريج لم تستطع
طواقم الاسعاف ولا طواقم الدفاع المدني
التوجه الى هذا المكان الى مخيم البريج لا
سما وان القصف الاسرائيلي استهدف مداخل
مخيم البريج وايضا القصف المدفعي مازال
مستمرا ومتواصلا وبالتالي عمليات القصف
تمنع دخول هذه السيارات لا سما وان هناك
قصف عنيف وهذا يشكل خطوره على هذه
السيارات الان عمليه التشييع ستتم صلاه
بعد قليل و من ثم سينطلق الزملاء الصحفيون
ل المقبره من اجل دفنه دفن الزميل جبر
وعائلته وجميع الشهداء الذين سقطوا في
استهداف لمنازل في مخيم المغازي وسط قطاع
غزه وايضا في مخيم النصيرات وكذلك في
منطقه الزوايده حيث استهدف الجيش
الاسرائيلي على مدار الساعات الماضيه على
الاقل ثلاثه منازل في مخيم النصيرات ومنزل
في منطقه الزوايده و منزل في مخيم المغازي
بالاضافه الى المنازل التي استهدفها في
مخيم البريج ولكن لم تستطع سيارات الدفاع
المدني ولا حتى الصحفيون التوجه الى هذا
المكان من اجل الحصول حتى على المعلومه في
مخيم البريج باتت صعبه للغايه في ظل
استمرار الاستهداف الاسرائيلي وبكل تاكيد
هذا الاستهداف وهذه المنطقه ليست الوحيده
ف كافه مناطق قطاع غزه تتعرض الى قصف لا
سما في المنطقه الشرقيه لرفح نعم في اخر
التطورات ايضا استهداف
لمخيم جباليا مره اخرى في شمال القطاع الى
جانب هذا الاستهداف المستمر ايضا لهذه
المخيمات
الموجوده في وسط القطاع لكن ابقى الان في
نطاق ما تتحدث عنه تعليقا على هذه الصوره
وهذه الوقفه امام جثمان الشهيد الصحفي جبر
ابو هدروس وسته من افراد عائلته الذين
استشهدوا في القصف الذي استهدف
منزلهم هشام عن استشهاد الصحفيين واستهداف
الجسم الصحفي في قطاع غزه وعائلات
الصحفيين ايضا ما الذي يحصيه او تحصه
السلطات الرسميه بهذا الخصوص وا الكلام
ايضا عن الظروف التي تعملون فيها انتم
كصحافيين في قطاع غزه في هذه
الحرب هي ظروف صعبه سواء من قبل الاستهداف
من قبل الجيش الاسرائيلي او حتى التحرك
الى المناطق التي يمكن رصد فيها طبيعه
الاحداث والتعرف عن قرب على هذه الاحداث
الجيش الاسرائيلي يواصل قصف واستهداف
الصحفيين اكثر من 100 صحفي على مدار هذه
الحرب المستمره على قطاع غزه استشهدوا من
جراء هذا القصف الاسرائيلي سواء من
الاستهداف المباشر لهؤلاء الصحفيين وهم
يغطون وهم على راس عملهم عملهم وهم يلبسون
هذه الدروع الواقيه وهذا اللباس الذي يشير
الى انهم صحفيين ولكن رغم كل ذلك استهدفهم
الجيش الاسرائيلي او حتى استهدف المنازل
التي يسكنون فيها او حتى استهدف عائلاتهم
ونحن نتحدث عن الصحفيين بكل تاكيد نستذكر
زميلنا سامر ابو دقه الذي استشهد وهو يعمل
ويقوم بعمليه التغطيه في خانيونس جنوب
قطاع غزه وكان يلبس كل هذا هذه الاشارات
التي تشير الى انه صحفي ولكن رغم كل ذلك
استهدفه الجيش الاسرائيلي في المره الاولى
واصيب اصابات بالغه وبعد ذلك اعاد القصف
مره جديده بعدما كان الزميل سامر قد حاول
الخروج من هذه المنطقه والذ ذهاب الى مكان
يستطيع اسعاف ان يقله او يجليه الى
المستشفى ولكن رغم كل ذلك استهدفه الجيش
الاسرائيلي ومنع سيارات الاسعاف من الوصول
اليه ومنع المسعفين من اسعافه وبالتالي
عمليات الاستهداف هي عمليات مستمره
ومتواصله والصحفيون في قلب هذه الاحداث
ويضحون بحياتهم من اجل ان تبقى التغطيه
مستمره شكرا جزيلا لك هشام زقوط كنت معنا
من مستشفى شهداء الاقصى في دير البلح ah